[Music]
thank you
Vanessa Bryant honors her late husband
Kobe and daughter Gianna on Dia de los
Muertos
[Music]
Vanessa is celebrating the holiday also
known as Day of the Dead rocking
traditional attire and skull makeup Dia
de los Muertos which is widely observed
in Mexico is a time to honor loved ones
who've died and Vanessa who's of Mexican
heritage pays tribute to Kobe and Gigi
through fashion the mom of four writes
in her caption Amor eterno which means
eternal love Dia de los Muertos Kobe and
Gigi
[Music]
in a second post Vanessa gives credit to
the designer and describes what the
details mean the number two on my sacred
heart for my Gigi the golden basketball
Halo with 24 stars from my husband the
six butterflies on my flower crown
representing my family everything is so
heartfelt and thought out
[Music]
earlier this week Vanessa's two youngest
daughters Capri and Bianca also pay
tribute to their Latin Heritage dressing
up as characters from Disney's Encanto
for Halloween
[Music]
share these adorable shots Capri as
Isabella and Bianca dressed as Dolores
[Music]
paces
[Music]
it's been over two years since Kobe and
Gigi's death we love and miss you miss
you baboon Gigi and Vanessa doesn't miss
a moment to recognize special occasions
in August she celebrated what would have
been the late NBA star's 44th birthday
sharing this sweet throwback photo
writing happy birthday baby I love you
and miss you so much Natalia also gave a
shout out to her dad saying happy
birthday Daddy what have you learned
about how to be strong and continue and
succeed I mean honestly I've learned the
most just from each other I think just
being able to rely on each other and be
there for each other has been like the
biggest inspiration
[Music]
thank you